en el vídeo anterior les mencioné que
las cosas se pondrían locas y lo son en
esta imagen este círculo del sistema
solar no es el tamaño del sol tampoco es
el tamaño de las órbitas de la tierra o
de plutón ni del cinturón de kuiper esto
es más cercano a la nube de oort y en
realidad el diámetro de la órbita de la
tierra es una fracción muy pequeña de
esto ni siquiera lo podemos ver no es ni
un píxel de esta pantalla porque si no
podemos ver nuestro sol no podemos ver
algo más pequeño recordemos que la
órbita de la tierra es una distancia muy
grande se necesitan ocho minutos para
que la luz del sol llegue a la tierra
pero si disparamos una bala al sol desde
la tierra la bala tardaría 17 años en
llegar al sol y aún así no podemos ver
esa distancia tan grande en
imagen ahora en el vídeo anterior
dijimos que si viajamos a velocidades
hiper rápidas como por ejemplo si
viajamos a 60 mil kilómetros por hora
que es la velocidad a la que viaja la
sonda espacial voyager 1 creo que ese es
el objeto más rápido que hemos lanzado
al espacio incluso puede estar dejando
el sistema solar mientras hablamos si
pudiéramos viajar tan rápido nos tomaría
80 mil años entre 75 mil y 80 mil años
viajar los 4.2 años-luz al cúmulo de
estrellas alfa centauri así que viajar a
la estrella más cercana nos tomaría 80
mil años y esa escala de tiempo es una
cantidad de tiempo enorme tan sólo
imaginen la civilización moderna se ha
desarrollado en los últimos 10.000 años
y gran parte de la historia que
conocemos
hace 4000 o 5000 años pero aquí
necesitaríamos 80 mil años para viajar a
la estrella más cercana es una distancia
enorme otra forma de verlo es que si el
sol fuera del tamaño de una pelota de
básquetbol y por ejemplo la ponemos en
londres si pensamos en escala la
estrella más cercana es una pelota más
pequeña que aquí sería proxima centauri
esa pelota más pequeña tendría que estar
en kiev ucrania kiev ucrania para que la
escala fuera similar entonces estas son
nuestras pelotas de basketball en
diferentes ciudades y necesitaríamos
viajar alrededor de 1.200 millas para
encontrar la otra pelota y por ejemplo
cada planeta sería apenas del tamaño de
un grano de arena tendríamos granos de
arena en kiev
y granos de arena en londres así que
esta es una distancia demasiado
demasiado grande es inimaginable y todo
se vuelve una locura cuando observamos
que incluso esto es una distancia muy
pequeña en comparación a la escala
galáctica en esta imagen
todo esto corresponde a aproximadamente
30 años luz 30 años luz y bueno podemos
tomar algunas fotografías de la galaxia
desde nuestro punto de vista pero no
podemos tomar una fotografía de toda la
galaxia desde arriba así que esta es
sólo una imagen supuesta pero si todo
esto es igual a 30 años luz entonces
todo esto es aproximadamente usaré un
color obscuro todo esto es igual a mil
años luz
mil años luz estos son los mil años luz
más cercanos a nuestro sol y nos tomaría
80 mil años luz poder llegar a otro
sistema solar al más cercano en realidad
nos tomaría muchísimo tiempo llegar a
algún lugar por eso es una locura esto
sería aproximadamente un poco más de un
píxel en esta imagen que se expande mil
años luz y cuando lo ponemos en
perspectiva es decir si nos alejamos
esta imagen de mil años luz corresponde
a esta parte todo esto es lo que hay más
cercano a nuestro sol aunque no tiene
nada de cerca entonces aquí hay una
distancia de mil años luz pero si
nosotros nos encontramos aquí en la
tierra y observamos un objeto que se
encuentra a 500 años luz lo que veremos
es cómo era ese
hace 500 años antes porque la luz que
llega a nuestros ojos a través del
telescopio dejó a ese objeto hace 500
años incluso puede que ya no exista en
este momento o que se movió de lugar así
que aún en esta escala
estamos hablando de distancias
impresionantes que ni siquiera podemos
imaginar y cuando ampliamos la escala
todo esto es la parte más cercana a
donde nos encontramos en el espacio esta
parte se conoce como el brazo o espolón
de orión mucha gente está tratando de
calcular con más detalle el tamaño
actual de la galaxia en la que nos
encontramos es decir de la vía láctea
pero están seguros de que existen estos
brazos es un poco difícil entender la
forma especialmente porque no podemos
ver mucho de la galaxia pero
entenderlo un poco todas estas
distancias tan enormes corresponden a un
pequeño puntito aquí ahora si nos
alejamos todavía más ya no alcanzamos a
ver el punto en esta imagen y toda esta
imagen corresponde a esta pequeña parte
solo a esta parte espero que puedan
visualizar lo pequeño que es todo lo que
tenemos cerca de nosotros en comparación
a la galaxia la galaxia tiene
aproximadamente de 200 a 400 mil
millones de estrellas mil millones de
estrellas o mejor dicho sistemas solares
sólo para aclarar que un sistema solar
no es solamente el sol sino que
comprende un montón de cosas más como
planetas y asteroides así que existen
entre 200 y 400 billones de sistemas
solares en esta galaxia
eso es algo enorme y muy complejo
entonces aun cuando tenemos esta imagen
existen miles de estrellas y cuando
observamos esta imagen cada pequeño
espacio no es una estrella ni miles de
estrellas sino que estamos hablando de
millones de estrellas y puede que
tengamos estrellas que se encuentran un
poco cerca o estrellas que se encuentren
muy lejos aunque en la imagen parezca
que están cerca pero incluso esta no es
la galaxia más grande podríamos hablar
de otras galaxias como por ejemplo la
galaxia de andrómeda muchas personas
creen que esa galaxia tiene un billón de
sistemas solares y estaríamos hablando
de distancias gigantescas pero solo para
que tengan una idea de en donde nos
encontramos nuestro sol se encuentra
aproximadamente aquí
y este pequeño punto corresponde a un
millón de sistemas solares separados por
distancias enormes pero recuerden que
esta es sólo una imagen supuesta en
realidad no podemos ver la galaxia desde
esta perspectiva porque nos llevaría
muchísimo tiempo viajar tan lejos para
ver la galaxia desde arriba así que esta
es la mejor forma de poder imaginarlo
incluso desde la tierra no podemos ver
toda esta área porque se encuentra del
otro lado del centro de la galaxia y
como el centro es muy denso y brillante
resulta difícil ver el otro lado incluso
se dice que en el centro de la galaxia
hay un agujero negro y también se dice
que hay un centro de las galaxias pero
el objetivo de este vídeo es que tengan
una idea de lo grande que es el universo
si pensamos en la escala no hay palabras
que puedan describir
pero nos encontramos aproximadamente a
25.000 años luz del centro de la galaxia
así que aún cuando lográramos ver algo
en el centro de la galaxia lo veríamos
como era hace 25 mil años porque la luz
tardó 25 mil años en llegar a nosotros
cuando esa luz dejó el centro de la
galaxia ni siquiera sabemos cómo era la
humanidad en ese momento entonces
tenemos estas distancias enormes en toda
la galaxia todos estos sistemas solares
y bueno es difícil delimitar la galaxia
porque siempre habrá algo más orbitando
pero podemos decir que el tamaño
aproximado del disco principal es de 100
mil años luz el diámetro de la parte
principal de esta galaxia es de
aproximadamente 100 mil años luz y
también tiene
un grosor de aproximadamente mil
años-luz esta imagen es plana pero
imaginen un disco que tiene un grosor de
mil años-luz
tendríamos que multiplicar esta
distancia 250 veces para pasar de abajo
hasta arriba de la galaxia así que
aunque en esta imagen parece que la
galaxia es plana en realidad es
inmensamente gruesa y esta es otra forma
de visualizar la si esta parte incluye a
la nube de oort tiene un diámetro de
aproximadamente un año luz eso lo
podríamos comparar con un milímetro de
un grano de arena y si es tan pequeño
entonces todo el universo es del
diámetro de un campo de fútbol así es
como podemos entenderlo imaginen un
milímetro de un grano de arena en un
campo de fútbol pero recuerden que ese
grano de arena es cincuenta mil o seis
mil veces más grande que el diámetro de
la órbita terrestre pero incluso en la
órbita terrestre si lanzamos una bala o
cualquier objeto que pueda viajar a la
velocidad de un avión necesitaría 15 16
o 17 años pero necesitaría muchos años
para llegar a la mitad de esa distancia
podemos decir que necesitaría 30 años
para cubrir el diámetro de la órbita
terrestre y bueno solo para darnos una
idea ésta hizo una fotografía de nuestra
galaxia la vía láctea desde nuestra
perspectiva observen que al estar dentro
de la galaxia estamos viendo hacia el
centro y nos podemos dar una idea de
cómo se ven 100 billones de estrellas
pero lo que me gustaría que observemos
en esta imagen es que cuando vemos todo
esto aunque parece que son algunas
estrellas en realidad son miles o
millones de éste
tal vez veamos una estrella cerca pero
conforme nos acerquemos al centro de la
galaxia
veremos millones de estrellas o sistemas
solares así que resulta muy complicado
entender todo lo que podríamos encontrar